huit délégations invitées mais en tout
cas ce dont je peux respirer je peux
confirmer déjà sept équipes invitées on
peut pas aller de une sélection de la
belgique on peut parler d'une sélection
de la grande bretagne
on peut parler une sélection des
etats-unis puis ce qui saute de partout
on peut parler de l'équipe nationale
sélection de santo domingo
on peut parler de deux de l'équipe de
aux environs de toulouse qui est une
équipe qui forment des professionnels
pour les lendemains dissipe les
martiniquais une équipe française
on peut parler aussi de la sélection de
guadeloupe où ils sont là en pleine
réflexion parce que il ya des garçons
qui marche comme si au pain comme karen
et puis là nous avons aussi la sélection
de la guyane j'ai un petit verre nous
envoyer très rapidement salissent je
sais pas si j'ai tout du tout j'ai tout
parlé à tient le guatemala qui figure
sur la liste nous attendons le tracé du
guatemala ainsi que la fin une
inscription à côté ça nous avons les
clubs de martinique
en octobre deux clubs des clubs bien
constitués et là je confirme je confirme
il n'y a pas de discrimination nous
avons demandé tous les clubs le vase
unique de s'inscrire le plus vite que
possible avec un délai à la fiche et
aujourd'hui nous sommes en possession
des forces en présence mardi une caisse
du tout le peloton le 120 coureurs sur
un parcours de sélection
un peloton à peu près de 120 110
coureurs un taux de vente unique cette
année beaucoup plus difficile de pas des
kilomètres qui sont beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus longs plus de 1000 km
affiche la commission technique a
travaillé pour permettre à ceux-ci
puissent d'évoluer parce que avant nous
avons des petites étapes et quinze jours
après on allait faire le tour de la ba
de la boîte d'auckland en souffrent
énormément parce que moi de loupe
c'est beaucoup plus de kilomètres tout
est en place fin prêts nous sommes dans
les derniers réglages
pourquoi ce tour de martinique puis 7 un
tour à succès il y aura des étapes de
montagne comme cette étape qui
l'inévitable étape de décision
aujourd'hui nous le faisons un peu plus
tard dans le tour ça veut dire avant
nous faisons le lundi matin
on faisait faux lefranc macouba tandis
que nous reculons au mardi le mardi nous
ferons trinité macouba une étape
décisive votre avc fort-de-france et
puis allez gravir toutes les montées du
littoral l'étape décisive et puis il ya
une récupération le lendemain en parlant
de macumba sainte marie mais il va
falloir grimpé quand même en martinique
il n'y a pas moyen de ne pas grimper
nîmois tout côté donc nous essayons
d'équilibrer au niveau de la commission
technique
pourquoi ils puissent avoir un beau
spectacle se pose une question si
concernant toujours les coureurs
effectuent un coureurs par équipe
démenti eh ben j'ai vu que la
pilotis a inscrit ses deux vénézuéliens
ça sera un cetain faute pratiquement à
l'unanimité des présidents de clubs pour
équilibrer la participation des clubs de
martigues dans le tour c'est trop facile
d'aller s'acheter deux vénézuéliens ou
deux étrangers à droite et à gauche
lorsque les autres ne peuvent pas le
faire
ça sera un vénézuélien la paix la
pilotine aura à choisir le meilleur
retour de martin guerre autour de
cyclisme de chez nous ont présenté sa
délégation